good morning everybody and welcome to
this virtual informal meeting of
mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley i'm the
leader of mid-suffolk district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
the decision to hold an informal meeting
has been taken as a result of the
current risks relating to the kovit 19
pandemic
as this meeting is now an informal
meeting the cabinet will not be able to
make decisions and therefore there will
be no voting on any items on the agenda
members are asked to debate the items on
the agenda and to confirm a steer for
each item which will then be
which will be recorded and decisions may
then be taken by officers or the leader
under delegation depending upon that
decision
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
not to post comments or questions
and please note that messages in the
chat panel can be viewed by people
watching the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this informal meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair um
this morning we have attending the
meeting councillor keith wellem chair of
the ovu and scrutiny committee counselor
dave muller chair of the joint ordered
and standards committee
we also have a other council attending
we have councillor andrew millen
council john madison and council john
field
of officer we have attending the chief
executive
the assistant director for corporate
resources and section 151 officer the
assistant director customers digital
transformation and improvement
and we also have the corporate manager
for policy performance and insight and
me i'm the governor's officer
and if i have
admitted anybody please can you let me
know now and
you can introduce yourself
thank you
that's fine thank you very much
henriette
and i'm now going to move to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
yes chair would you like me to do a roll
call for oh yes please members we
haven't received any apologies this
morning so i'll continue with the roll
call okay uh counselor david burn
are you present counselor david bern
yes i am sorry i couldn't marry so
quickly enough council julie flatman
present
council jessica fleming
present
council peter gold
present
council of vineyard hadingham president
council susie morley
a present
uh councillor harry richardson
present
council john whitehead yeah i'm present
and counselor jared brewster
present
that is everybody's friend jan
thank you item two is to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
no thank you
item three
is mca
21 33 and this is to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 6th of
december 2021.
uh these me these minutes
will be deferred to the next cabinet
meeting
item four is to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme are there any
thank you
and
item five is questions by counsellors
um we have a few uh questions that have
come in so question one i'm going to
invite councillor matheson
to ask his question to the cabinet
member for finance
[Music]
jerry i understand that council of
mellon has um asked the same set of
questions essentially so i think i'd
like to withdraw in favor of him asking
his questions instead
okay thank you councillor matheson
um question two is council matheson to
the cabinet member for the environment
oh yeah that applies to all four
questions that i submitted
okay thank you very much
um
and
counselor melon you have count question
four
is your question for the cabinet member
for finance
and this item is would you like to ask
your question now and then we'll respond
to it under item 10.
[Music]
yeah sure thank you um sorry i think i
only adopted one of john's questions but
if i ask mine first
um can we have his other ones as the
supplementaries is that okay
um you can ask one supplementary
okay
the question i had is uh
why is the joint audit committee's
reasonable and balanced recommendation
on divesting our treasury investments
from fossil fuel companies
which was taken unanimously on may the
17th 2021
not being acted on
thank you councillor mellon we'll
respond to that under item
10. and perhaps i can suggest that in
future so that we don't have this um
confusion around questions that all
questions come via the leader of the
opposition so that then you don't get
several people asking the same ones and
getting in a bit of a muddle
so
noted yet noted thank you chair yes it
was rather last minute but uh yes we
will try and do that okay thank you very
much everybody
so item six
is matters referred by overview and
scrutiny or the joint audit and
standards committees
[Music]
no matters are received jan
thank you
and item seven is the forthcoming
decisions list does anybody have any
comments
[Music]
okay
can we just pause the
recording for a moment please officers
thank you
item eight is the
outcomes framework report mca 21-34
i am the cabinet member for customers
digital transformation
and improvement
this report identifies
the need for an outcomes framework to
achieve a golden thread between the
corporate plan the six strategic
priorities the service plans and
personal plans and to ensure the
corporate delivery plan is delivering
the right activities for our residents
and their communities
you will remember that we as cabinet
members contributed to the development
of the outcomes at the cabinet slt away
day in october and officers presented
the updated framework in december that
we are being asked to agree today
the new approach shifts the focus of
measurement and reporting away from
highlighting activities outputs and
performance indicators
to an emphasis on outcomes that can
demonstrate the impact of the council's
strategies policies and plans
the framework has the council vision in
tier one followed by 18 strategic
outcome statements in tier 2
this is 3 for each strategic priority
these are supported by a short-term and
flexible range of 66 intermediate
outcomes in tier 3 that will form the
core of all outcomes an insight
monitoring approach
it will help us to make sure we spend
our money on the agreed outcomes for our
residents and customers
it also seeks to drive strategic change
and improvements and
provide a golden thread for strategy and
business planning arrangements
it is the new performance management
approach in the direction of travel for
reporting embedding a culture of
performance challenge and improvement
we are asked to agree
three recommendations
agree the first three tiers of of the
outcomes framework as the new strategic
approach to measuring performance of the
council
and to note that slt will work with
corporate managers to develop tier 4 of
the framework relating to specific
measures outputs and kpis which will
follow in tandem with the 2022-23
service planning cycle
and future quarterly progress reports on
the outcomes framework and the corporate
delivery plan
and to delegate any minor changes to
this framework to the ad for customer
digital transformation improvement
in consultation with the portfolio
holder
so
thank you
everybody i would like to call for a
second for this
yes chair happy to second
lovely thank you councillor flatman
um
questions from members i'm going to go
around the cabinet first councillor bern
now i have i have no question just at
the moment thank you
thank you councillor flatman
no questions chair at the moment thank
you
councillor fleming
no questions thank you
councillor gould
um
i thought i had a question i've become
slightly nervous in the last
minute
colleagues
it's it's for um for cancer richardson
and um
it it's really you made in your
introduction uh reference to uh to a
golden thread tying
uh tying policies and actions together
at all levels i'm i'm very interested to
know from harry um
now we've we've adopted the excellent
well-being strategy how that is
influencing shaping being taken on
by the county's uh well-being board i'd
be just interested to to to know that
richardson
thank you chair thank you uh councillor
gould i think there's actually sort of
two key points i'd like to emphasize one
is just on that sort of golden thread
point because that's actually something
i've been reflecting on when we're
producing this outcomes framework that
when we adopted the well-being strategy
back in september one of the things that
we made really clear was it's not just a
standalone document but something that
we wanted to or the principles and the
outcomes and the objectives within it is
something we wanted to see embedded
across the whole organization including
all of our other um strategic priorities
so i think that's a really important
aspect of this outcomes framework is
that it embeds well-being right at the
core of our corporate plan exactly as
you said uh councillor morley in terms
of the health and wellbeing board i
think there's a really good opportunity
here for us to work more closely with
the county council there's
a refresh of their outlook
and their strategy now that councillor
hicks
is tearing that particular board and i
think there's a real opportunity now
that we've got this um framework now
that we've got the strategy in place for
well-being to really define what our
offer is to our county colleagues and i
know that with our assistant director
for communities and wellbeing we're
already working very closely with some
of our ccgs um but then at a ground
level we're also doing a lot of work
with the integrated neighborhood teams
so i think that from mid suffolk's
perspective this gives us a really nice
opportunity now that we've got this
defined and really set out in in clear
detail how we can we can make an impact
across our district so i think this is a
really exciting opportunity for us so i
definitely think this will help
embed our work with those of our
colleagues across the health and social
care sector thank you chair
thank you councillor richardson
uh councillor hattingham
no questions thank you i'm very happy
with the framework
council richardson
nothing for me thank you chair council
whitehead
sorry no questions just happy to take
part in the debate later thank you
councillor brewster
yeah the same uh madam chair no
questions but i'll take a place on this
on the um
debate
okay um
henriette
yes yeah uh sorry if i may just
interrupt briefly um just to let you
know that we do not need a proposal and
a second seconder in this informal
meeting today so just make sure that we
don't you know we don't we don't need
that today okay thank you very much
thank you
i'm now going to invite questions from
non-cabinet members press present
if you could put your hand up
that would be helpful
cancer field
thank you
obviously a very pretty framework
clearly expressed
i was just wondering if you had got some
firm time scales for the uh tier four
our outputs and activities
which seem to be somewhat critical
for instance wildflower planting
enhances the landscape of our districts
but you know
where do we go from there
um i think we're
we're already in discussions about
timings on that conversations are
already happening
on that particular item i don't know
whether councillor fleming you've got
any insight on the wildflower pack it
was really a matter of anything
yes we've already started having having
conversations and they will be um
ongoing as soon as this framework is is
approved
yeah i i i sorry i can confirm
that we are on target with the
wildflower planting and that
our officer will bucknell is working
with all the relevant communities and
parishes that have expressed an interest
including quite a few individuals as
well so i think i see this as being a
very successful program in the coming
year
so in in the wider context the um tier 4
conversations will will be starting as
soon as this is finished as soon as this
is approved
thank you
and will be completed
i don't see this as being
something that has a particular
completion date
john it's an ongoing program
yeah
thank you thank you
thank you john uh councillor wellam
thank you chair um yeah you may recall
the overview and scrutiny meeting when
we first looked
at keith can i just ask you to adjust
your camera because i can only see you
know the top of my head sorry
thank you
we um
joined ov scrutiny looked at the
original sort of framework back in
january 2020 and i recall asking a
question about the outcomes and when
um and there was quite a debate about
the outcomes of that meeting um and i
was told in january 2020 that i would
see the outcomes uh the list of outcomes
very soon um and now i believe we see
them some two years later but but sober
yet we've got the we've got the list of
outcomes but one of quite a bit of the
discussion at that meeting was around
getting uh all member buy-in to almost
to anything that the council's put
forward so
my question is what steps have been
taken what further steps will be taken
to encourage all members to buy into
firstly the tier 3 and then subsequently
to the tier 4 outcomes
um i believe we are planning um some
frame uh workshops around this
but um
i wonder if
um
jane
is
in with us whether jane you can help
i i am what is the exact format that
this will take hi i am indeed here uh
[ __ ] so we we already have done uh a
lot of memory engagement in
in december so we engaged um
with or with all parties um in in both
councils in in december
on the um on the outcomes um to date
um following um engagement in in october
so we've we've already engaged um
with all parties um on on the tiers one
to three outcomes and now um as we need
to move into into service planning
um
and
ready for for quarter of course one
reporting
okay
sure just just come back and um
you may recall that the discussion was
around the benefit of all member
briefings because
the all member briefings at that time
were being attended by something less
than 40 percent of all members and our
concern as a joint overview of scrutiny
was how do we get by and from the people
who don't
want don't seem to want to engage and
don't attend
um uh briefings and
there was a brief discussion around
trying to find
different methods of engaging with the
people who don't come to briefings so i
mean there isn't an answer to that
that's fine i'll just leave it there i
think i think it's the responsibility of
of all
of all councillors to to engage and
the the group leaders have a
responsibility to make sure that even if
those members are not attending the all
member briefing
um presumably amongst their own our own
group meetings we should be encouraging
and soliciting views of our wider groups
and
you know we you can
you can provide a horse with water but
you can't force them to drink so um
you know we do everything we can to make
sure that members have access to all
member briefings
um
it really is up to group leaders to make
sure members attend
um perhaps i can bring in the chief exec
at this point
thank you councillor i was just going to
add in relation to councillor williams
original question that the outcomes
framework as you'd expect is heavily
based upon the key strategies that the
council has adopted over the last couple
of years most recent one has already
been mentioned during the meeting that
the well-being strategy of course all of
those strategies have had engagement
pre-adoption but most fundamentally were
adopted at full council so there has
been that additional layer of governance
or
engagement rather with all councils
through that process but i i take
council willem's point which is um we
can always do more and we can always
look to see how we can engage although
you're right counselor morley and we
can't always force them to drink
we'll do our best though keith
thank you
so if we're if we're now no more
questions so i'm going to open up the
item for discussion
so i think
again i'll i'll go
um no we'll go to hands up for for a
discussion i think
so any
any cabinet members wish to
engage in discussion on this
councillor whitehead
sorry just just moving to
just changing the windows and i lost the
opportunity to take the microphone off
um right thank you
i do like this document because any
resident reading the report can quite
clearly see what our priorities of this
concept administration are um i mean
just looking at the tier two strategic
outcomes it clearly shows that our focus
is on the health and well-being and
children having the best start in life a
local economy having strong growth with
innovation and creativity
our communities attractive successful
and connected places people living work
our residents have affordable and high
quality homes
our customers can access high quality
services and support
and we value enhance and protect our
environment and i mean these are all
very laudable priorities which i fully
support and endorse
but i do think it's a great credit to
our officers that they've been able to
pull all this together in such a clear
concise and very readable way that's my
thoughts on it
thank you john councillor brewster
thank you military
um
yes i think this is this is a really
good document to to
work with
and we can see the priorities
and and how they are being dealt with
quite regularly
i mean looking at my own
portfolio
i think that shows everything that
that i would wish to see happening
within that portfolio and i'm sure that
the other ones uh other members would be
perhaps you know the same
um it's it's a very useful document for
uh catholic members as well as all the
wider community and the wider council um
force
so
yeah i think it's a really really good
document and and very pleased to see it
come forward
thank you gerard councillor fleming
just thank you um
i must say i'm i'm really impressed with
this document i think um
it's very clear and it sets things out
in a strategic manner that we wish to
achieve
it's not intended to provide a lot of
detail
and that is obviously
something separate but um it gives us a
steering wheel we want to go and i just
want to um
you know just look at the environment um
category where we
just to take a a quick look at that um
if we might it's on page 26
we've got three
overarching um
objectives here by to enhance
biodiversity
to reduce the carbon footprint and
healthier safer and sustainable places
and on biodiversity i think we know that
biodiversity net gain is something we're
not just don't just want to do but we're
going to have to do and my hope is that
we will be able to meet and exceed the
targets that government are setting us
in the environment bill
we will
things like wildflower planting and
planting trees and hedges etc these
aren't programs that have an end date
there are ongoing commitments that the
council is making
um
and i just think that people need to be
very clear these programs aren't a start
stop
event they are um they will continue
providing you know
we have our say in it
um carbon footprint that is also an
ongoing
real challenge for the council
and something where we need to and are
engaging with all of our partners and
technology providers to be able to
meet our obligations
as well as
keeping people
on board and i think there's a lot of
fear out there about
cost and price and affordability and
this is where we have to um find the
funds and do what we need to do in a way
that brings people along with us
and and finally the third bullet i think
is really important under environment
um that is healthier safer and
sustainable places and this is part of
our health and well-being strategy as
well to open up the environment and
and
the countryside so that it's accessible
we've had a motion to that effect and
this is something that i'm very excited
to be taking forward so that was just
what i wanted to say about the paper so
thank you very much to those who
prepared it
thank you thank you jess councillor
gault
thanks very much chair
and
of course uh
as jessica's just made reference to the
um sorry council flemish just made
reference to the
needs to
the importance of finding the
the funds to continue
to deliver this and to continue the work
and it's really on that aspect i wanted
to speak briefly of course my portfolio
is very much about providing the means
to
deliver uh to help deliver these
outcomes and i'm i'm i'm very pleased
and proud about that
uh and if we look
uh not only as an administration do we
have a very clear set of outcomes uh
which is uh
ambitious
uh but deliverable and it's one of the
reasons that makes it deliverable is the
strong financial position that we have
as a council so i cannot but uh link
this uh
set of outcomes
to the strength of our financial
position because writing many councils
can write
sets of ambitious outcomes few have them
always have the means to deliver them we
are one of those councils and we should
be very proud of that i think
absolutely thank you peter
um
council bern
um
yes thank
you chair um
mike
cancer burn you've gone on to
i mute understand that sorry
start again yeah yeah my portfolio
planning um
doesn't have a
corporate priority all of its own um
one or two portfolios do but um a little
like uh councillor ghouls um
it it crosses uh it crosses over many of
of the priorities and the other
portfolios and um
i am
extremely pleased to see
uh
in uh one or two of these areas um
uh items that
uh planning can certainly make a very
strong contribution to
um and i i i it's a good steer for for
me to to
guide the planning service
you've gone on to mute again david
does that keep happening
it's the gremlins again
a gremlin yes indeed anyway you can
still hear me i don't know where i've
got to um
i'd i'd got to saying that um
several of these uh
priorities do cross into uh planning or
at least planning can can support them
and planning uh
does support them i'm particularly
concerned uh or interested in the areas
of uh environment the extent to which
planning can
both impinge on and and help
um the
environment
i'm also
keen to see
the the housing one and
we we do support we do support that and
um
with building control and um improvement
uh to um
the environmental contributions that
housing makes in terms of
um
economy of of
carbon emissions and so on so forth we
can improve the situation
uh there um but in particular i'm i'm
keen to see
that the community's uh outcomes
are assisted as much as possible by
planning and um
uh there i think the the um the
involvement that the communities can
have and do have in the planning process
goes a long way towards achieving these
thank you
thank you david councillor richardson
thank you chair it was just to build on
some of the remarks that some of my
colleagues made earlier um and i think
touching on some of the things i
reference in terms of well-being
strategy um being embedded across the
whole organization what i think this
framework really does enable us to do is
to think more broadly about the outcomes
that we deliver
for our residents so we know for example
that there are broader determinants of
health and well-being and i think
linking explicitly the well-being um
objectives that we want to achieve
within the broader work that we do as a
council is absolutely essential for many
of the reasons that councillor byrne and
councillor fleming mentioned that it's
not just
one particular portfolio working in
isolation or walking in a silo it's
about looking holistically at what we as
a council are delivering
and how we can improve the lives of our
residents and i think looking at this in
the whole is that going to be absolutely
essential to the work that we do and i
think it's a really helpful way
of visualizing and setting out what it
is we want to achieve so i will
definitely be supporting this thank you
chair
thank you harry councillor flatman
thank you chair
carrying on following on from all that's
been said
we do need the finances to make this all
work
we we don't work in silo we all talk to
each other we all make sure that
everything we want to achieve
is achievable
and at the heart of everything our
communities
is what we're here for and if we can
empower them
and create the the grants and the work
etc
the housing that everybody needs then
we've done our job and thank you to the
officers for pulling this all together
and it's so clear for our residents to
see thank you
thank you julie
i'm i'm really proud of of this document
and i would really like to thank
sarah wilcox and her whole team and
especially jane kennedy for for pulling
all this
together it's it's a really difficult
thing to show
in effectively
almost a one-dimensional paper
three-dimensional concepts
and
um several of you have already mentioned
that you know we we don't work in silos
anymore
and these
this tiered structure allows us to
um see across the piece
how
and where we can most support our our
residents
you've already mentioned
council fleming's already mentioned
under her environment portfolio about
mid-suffolk being healthier safer and
sustainable places to live and of course
that's not just about the environment
that covers our housing
portfolio it covers our communities
portfolio
planning portfolio as well as
environment and this gives us a really
good three-dimensional view
through
and enables us all to work together much
more closely
and less siloed to make sure that these
outcomes actually come to fruition in a
more cohesive strategy so i i'm i'm
really proud of this document and i'd
like to thank all of our officers and
all of our councillors who have
contributed to to all the every single
tiered item within this document it's a
fantastic piece of work i'm really proud
of it
so based upon the discussion i'm minded
to accept the recommendations unless
anybody disagrees and will pass that
forward to be
implemented
later
thank you everybody for your for your
discussions around this item
i'm now going to move on to item 9 which
is mca 21
35 and this is the fees and charges for
2022 to 2023 and i'm going to invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this
report thank you madam chairman um i'm
pleased to introduce report cabinet
paper mca 2135 which is the fees and
charges for 2223 which starts on page
said one of our report pack
but whilst i remember i'd like to bring
to members attention there are within
our additional table papers on page five
uh two changes from the fees and charges
set out appendix a
and these two changes relate to the
garden waste collection charges so for
existing subscribers and new subscribers
we're posing to add two pound to the
existing charges and that's in line with
the increase in cost we are facing from
our contractor
so the fees and charges for 2223 which
we are recommending today after built
into the draft 2223 general fund budget
um
so madam chairman i'm an avid follower
of social media especially of local
neighborhood groups as it's a great way
of keeping a finger on the pulse of what
is of interest and concern to our
residents
and inevitably within those our council
services get a mention and many several
times i've seen comments along the lines
of
all the council does is empty our bins
and to those people in indeed to members
and residents in general i would say
take a look through our fees and charges
schedule which starts on page 39 of our
pack and with its various schedules runs
through to page 90.
so we've got 52 pages of fees and
charges
and in total those fees and charges are
anticipated to bring in an income to the
council of 5.1 million pounds next year
the content pages shows fees and charges
in relation to our council services
for environmental licensing
for planning
building control land charges the green
environment hackney carriage and private
hire premises another licensing car
parking and the community infrastructure
levy and some of these are statutory and
some of the discretionary charges but
together they do highlight the sheer
breadth and depth of services that our
district council provides for our
residents and businesses
and of course there are many more
services we provide for free in the
communities public realm housing
well-being the economy the environment
planning and democratic services
so collectively the council does much
much more than just
empty our
bins and clearly this fees and charged
income of 5.1 million is one of the
major components of our total business
income
many fees and charges remain unaltered
from this year but where changes are
proposed
our service managers have reviewed them
and are confident that the proposed
changes have been benchmarked and have
been found to be reasonable and
proportionate
if members have any questions on our
fees and charges i'd be happy to answer
them thank you
thank you john
um so i'm going to go through
counsellors
individually uh to start with uh
councillor bern do you have a question
no i don't thank you
councillor flatman
uh no question at present madam
councillor fleming
no i don't have a question thank you
councillor gold
no question thanks councillor hattingham
no questions thank you
councillor richardson
nothing for me thank you chair
um
councillor brewster
no questions from me madam chair
and do we have any questions from any
non-cabinet members
counselor field
just one to john i guess um looking at
uh paragraph 5.5 on page 32 it says
um
the increase of 554k
or 12.2 percent
which is detailed elsewhere
i i mean i'm quite quite aware that the
treasury is predicting that inflation
will go to six percent this year uh due
to the effects of covid et cetera
and we all hope that's it um i just
wondered how
12.2 percent is is felt reasonable
right good question um
i think if i can just address your
attention to
appendix b
in on page what page is that page 37
because that that sets out a large table
which shows all the increases and um
if you go to the right hand column sort
of line by line it sort of shows what
those plenty of increases are so
although we're going from four point
five four six million up to five point
one million which you say is a twelve
percent increase
there's a whole range there many zeros
three percents
uh et cetera and um
i think really it just needs to be
looked at line by line and of course
some of these
that we're talking about the money
we're talking about
volume and price so um you know we could
some things that are frozen in price can
still bring in
say a 10 increase in in fees and incomes
not because we've put the price of it
because the demand is there so
that's that would be my answer to your
point
thank you for that can i just point out
obviously the increase in volume is
something i'm sure we'd all support and
i did look at your table which did
indicate things like civil parking
enforcement
with a 66
increase which did seem pretty dramatic
um and there are indeed some significant
reductions which are good to see for all
of us i'm sure but uh
street number one
and numbering is a 39 increase and i you
know
it would have been good if you perhaps
offered the volume and the inflationary
increase separately and then that would
ensure that our residents fully
understand thank you right okay well i
certainly can't answer those questions
immediately but i take the point you're
making
thank you very much
um so i'm now gonna open up the item for
for discussion
does anybody want to
start us off please put your hand up
okay so based upon that i'm minded to
accept the recommendations
i've heard nobody
disagree
okay
accepted
on to item 10
this is mca 21-36
and is the environmental social and
governance considerations for the
councillors council's treasury
management investments
um
i'm going to invite councillor whitehead
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce this report
thank you
thank you man chairman
before i start my speech i think
probably best to answer the question
that council mellon
was held over from the questions by
councillors section
um if i just
if i may on his behalf just read out
that question again it says why is the
joint audit committee recommendations to
divest our treasury investments from
foreign fossil fuel companies which was
taken unanimously
not being acted on um
now i've no doubt that council mellon
has sort of fully
thoroughly read this report but it's
his benefit i'd read out
paragraph 4.21
because i think this just clearly set
out the reason
and that paragraph says
it is believed that the discussion and
recommendation from joint audit and
standard committee was too narrowly
focused on the environmental aspects of
esg especially fossil fuels
and did not adequately address the wider
determinants under the social and
governance aspects
so an alternative recommendation has
therefore been put forward
for cabinet to consider
so that is my immediate answer to
councillor mellon's question i don't
know
if that's appropriate now for a
follow-up question or whether i should
just go straight on to
read out my
speech
i think carry on with your speech
councillor whitehead and uh can't bring
councillor melanie when we get to the
questions
okay right so
esg
environmental social and governance
i mean anyone in the financial
investment world cannot have escaped
just how much prominence and focus this
esg topic has recently been given
i sit on the civic county council
pensions committee as a district council
representative and every commission
meeting is proceeded with a member
training session and a great deal of
training time has been devoted in 21 to
esg
and as vice chair of that committee i
also sit on sessions where pension
officers and
meet up with individual fund managers
and again a lot of these meeting times
has been devoted to esg
quite a lot of time in these training
and management meeting sessions have
been devoted to the environmental
aspects
but certainly not the 95
plus of the committee time the joint
audience scrutiny devoted to the e
aspect
i mean social aspects are important
social aspects that covers things like
employee relations and diversity
working conditions local communities and
health and safety
and these are important for uk based
companies and i would say even more so
for those operating in the third world
the governor's aspects the g these are
also important this covers executive
remuneration donations and political
lobbying corruption and bribery board
diversity and structure
and again i'd say that's important not
only for uk companies but particularly
those operating in less developed parts
of the world
and therefore the revised recommendation
in paragraph 3.1
recommends that cabinet monitors all
three aspects of esg reporting
and makes changes where appropriate to
strengthen esg
performance now the environmental focus
of joint audit and scrutiny and indeed
the focus of the initial questions posed
by the opposition today
have been on just two aspects of five
overall aspects within the scope of
environmental namely climate change and
greenhouse gas emissions
and i want to address those now
i spent some time this saturday morning
actually listening to the recording of
may's joint audience scrutiny meeting
clearly several members there felt that
the appropriate time to make these
changes is either now
or very soon
the emphasis was on divesting from
fossil fuel assets and the risk of
stranded assets
i've also done quite a bit of reading
for these topics myself although i can't
profess to be an expert in either green
issues or indeed investment management
um but
i say it's been a lot in depressed
recently just this last friday gone the
major oil group shell released their
third quarter trading update and that
was an opportunity for financial
analysts
and commentators to give their thoughts
so what did they say
three quotes i've picked out
they said whatever happens shell will
remain an oil and gas giant for decades
they said shell shares look to remain
worthy of ongoing long-term support
and the average rating of stock market
analysts on a shell is
strong buy
and what has the press recently said
this another quote the fact is for now
the world is over still overwhelmingly
dependent on hydrocarbons for its energy
needs we're going to need the gas and
oil these companies produce
for a long time to come
drive the industry offshore if you must
by reducing britain to an investment
desert it only makes us even more
dependent on outside forces that care
little or nothing about the demand of
climate
another press quote these not my words
is from the press
hammering big oil will do nothing to
help fuel poverty or the climate
and they said they
by then the old majors like bp and shell
deserve a little tlc
yet in all fronts they are treated like
pariahs
we'll regret it once they're gone
so there it is in a nutshell if we and
the others in the uk divest such
companies as bp and shell it will put us
ever more at the mercy of the likes of
president putin or opec or other
foreign oil companies
for our oil and gas supplies
madam chairman it's really a case of
national security
do we want to growing reliance on the
goodwill of foreigners when europe as a
whole is short of energy and russia
intends to use its dominant position in
gas and oil
and coal as part of its diplomatic
leverage
i mean we're already starting to shoot
ourselves in the foot uk gas prices in
pence per firm
are up from 34 pence at the start of
last year to 2 pounds 36 per pence
by the end of 2021
our green colleagues talk about stranded
assets in regard to oil and gas i
thought about this during the hgv supply
difficulty this autumn when people were
queuing in desperation to refill their
tanks that was mothers on school runs
midwives needed to get to their work
much needed oil was then stranded at the
refineries whilst the desperate consumer
demand continued and that demand is not
going away anytime soon
i mean to be honest there's much more
i'd like to say but um given the need
for brevity i'll just give one more
quote before i wrap up
net zero watch says
we are heading down a path where blithe
promises are made without considering
the realities of current technology and
the fact that many people in this
country will be left colder and poorer
so in turns his recommendation
obviously was intending to move if we
had a formal meeting
um i think we need to concentrate on all
three aspects of esg in our treasury
management investments and i think we
need to rely on our investment experts
and the exceedingly well paid fund
managers to aid us in our fiduciary duty
regarding these investments and also i
trust will do nothing
sorry i trust we'll do our best to do
nothing that will leave our residents
colder and poorer thank you madam
chairman
thank you john thank you councillor
whitehead
um
i'm now going to see whether we've got
any questions counselor burn
it's an old hand i'm sorry
okay councillor flatman
sorry chair mine i can't see my hands up
so that must be no no no i'm going
through asking if anybody's got any
questions
sorry chair nothing at present thank you
councillor fleming no questions thanks
councillor gould
no questions thanks councillor
huddingham no questions thank you
councillor richardson
uh nothing for me thank you councillor
brewster
no questions monitoria thank you thank
you um so
non-cabinet members if you'd like to put
your hand up if you've got a question
try to find the way that yeah
cancel
so when i was trying to do that after
john put his hand up but there you go um
just a brief question looking at the um
the gist of the paper mentions that sort
of um
there seems to be a dearth of um
funds which are
have good principles if you say i and i
i noticed our list here has ccli um and
three others and ccla to the best of my
knowledge is an ethical fund
um and it does seem to have outperformed
the rest quite substantially
so there's sort of a question to john
there you know how does he justify those
points i know
um i have got another report here
actually from nick reed the director of
client investments at that ccli and it
does i think point out that ethical
funds can do quite well
um so so there's
could he say a bit a little bit more
about that perhaps
um the other point is that he made a lot
of point about him continuing to vest
and the oil will carry on for some time
but i know certainly the guardian has
been banging on for some time as you'd
expected to saying
that um it's actually the american
high-tech companies which are driving
market upwards at the moment and the
ones which um
scrutiny suggested we pulled out of
actually are not doing very well at all
wonder if he could quote
comment on those two points
right okay um
yes ccla i mean that's a great advert
for our cifco really the sort of
performance that
ccla has put in so you know i agree with
you very much on that
um
and uh but the conference is very much
properly orientated and
a recovery as we come out come out of
the worst aspects of covid i mean i
think a lot of these investments from
memory i think we've put them away
2017-2018 and obviously asg is very much
a
i'm not saying the flavor of the day but
it very much has sort of developed
really soon since that time
but um
um i'm not a guardian reader
i'm surprised to hear but
i'll do occasional look at their website
where they beg me for money um the high
tech and you know high tech is very much
u.s focused and um some of those
companies have just gone through the
roof where um
so
british companies sort of being left
behind a little bit
but i think um i've talked about shell
in my speech and
they're now worth 132 billion pounds
i've actually just overtaken astrazeneca
as the most um
valuable company in
in the uk so if you rank the companies
in the footsie
shell's number one and um
um
so the bp
and shell shares last year went up by
over 30 which sort of beat the index and
bear in mind they're a big part of the
index it
it just shows that how you know how
important those investments were
um to our to our performance last year
when i say performance to performance
the various funds we had
so um the uh yeah investment is a very
complicated game which is why i say we
leave it to our
highly paid fund managers
but um the uh
on any sort of objective
viewpoint i think um
certainly shares like shell and bp have
been good investments over the last 12
months and
important dividend payers
and
do an important service as i said
it was quite clear when the full court
suddenly ran dry just how valuable and
desperate people are for their product
thank you very much environment we could
debate we could talk about that for
ages some regrets but i'll point out
ccla's
main investment fund does somewhat
better than their property fund which
which is interesting
and i think apple are worth three
trillion whereas shallow worst 300
billion yeah okay yeah
and
i've tried susie's patience as much as i
could
have you never tried my patience john
please do that
thank you thank you johns
and another john councillor madison
thank you yes i was one of the members
of the audience standards committee last
may when
when these recommendations were put
together and at that time um
catherine steele was was very reluctant
to
to to move
uh the the investments
because of the
the size of the loss
um compare that would then be sustained
um or would we sustain the loss anyway
because the shares had gone down
but the um
she was reluctant to to declare this
um into the accounts which which it
would crystallize the loss
so i was a bit puzzled uh that um
council whitehead mentioned the the um
the contribution
that the um the particular funds um it
was showed us isn't it uh had had been
making and
i
um
on on the broader point that he makes
about the committee not discussing
discussing the social and governance
reasons i think that that would be good
discussion to have
and i think i would look at the
the billions billions of pounds and
dollars that have been put in by the
fossil fuel industry into lobbying
government
and media
so i have a question yeah what's the
question
the the question
the question i think that remains is
is that are what is the
the the gain or loss
that we would incur
if we sold the
investments as recommended last may
um what's the current position that that
was actually the part one of the
questions i submitted last um thursday
friday whenever it was thank you
cancer whitehead
right yes i was waiting for a question
there um the uh and of course councilman
mathen did submit the question i think
it's in the table of papers about the
current losses on investments yeah well
obviously day by day that changes but um
it's very difficult really with these
pooled investment funds to sort of drill
down into the
performance of sort of individual stocks
and everything um i think comics had
made in response to council of field in
terms of how
oil the oil shares have have performed
last year um
our section 151 officer
has express the reluctance to sort of
crystallize losses
in these investments while some of them
are are still under water and i think
the
it's the um
schroeder maximizer fund which seems a
bit of a
strange name actually maximizing looking
at it
looking at its performance but that's
the one that's still quite a bit
underwater but um
i think
the um
i certainly wouldn't recommend this camp
member for finance that we sort of
divested these um just to
transfer the holdings
into
ones that are sort of
fossil fuel free and mainly for all the
reasons i set out in the um
in my intuitive speech and whilst
analysts are still saying that shares
like
shell are a strong buy
i think um we'd be failing enough for
you to reduce if we did that but that's
my opinion i accept that we have
different opinions within our council
thank you thank you councilman
yes thank you chair um
it's just a supplementary question um
the
the risk management table
at um
8.1 in the report
does seem to refer to the original
uh recommendation from the
audit and standards rather than the new
recommendation
and i just wonder whether um the cabinet
member feels that the risks of holding
on to these invest investments is
reflected there
in the table
thank you
did you mean any particular risk in
particular andy or do you mean all of
them
well i think the risk um i'm concerned
about is obviously as john
mentions that some of the funds are uh i
think he's phrases underwater
um is there a risk of those funds
losing further value if we don't divest
from them
trying to free up my camera and got so
many windows open
um
no well again it's the uh let's say past
performances no guide to the future but
my own good instinct you know to come
out of covid and how the economy
well the global economy is expected to
improve
is that um
these investments should
improve in the future
and it's my personal opinion that
well
the more the more diverse they are that
the more the risks are spread out and
if if that includes some fossil fuel
companies including the likes of bp and
shell which are
very large multinational uh corporations
it's my personal view that the risks are
reduced rather than increased
thank you
okay
um so i'm going to now open up this item
for discussion
um would anybody like to
put their hand up cancer muller
um
thank you thank you very much chair um
basically what i would like to say i i
have been given the latest um figures
regarding the these investments as of
the 31st of december which i think you
might be interested in
and with a cclo ccla property okay the
amount invested was 5 million but the
actual book value the actual
value is actually currently 5 5.3
million and it's actually increased from
5.046 million as of the 31st of uh 31st
december so that's gone up with the
schroder maximizer fund the investment
valuation was at the end of september
1.586 million and it's now 1.662
million so that's obviously gone up
again the ubs multi asset fund is
increased from 1.831 million at the end
of september to 1.841
million at the end of december and the
invest tech 91 series diverse income
account has gone up from 1.939 million
to
1.956 million at the 31st december so i
accept they're still below the actual
amount invested but at the moment those
those um
assets we have are actually increasing
in value on the current stock market
values i think that's a really really
important point i think the other
important point we we raised at the
actual uh
jsat committee in may was that we
recognized that any decision to withdraw
funds should be balanced against any
financial prudence because obviously we
don't want to make huge losses
on the council investments and i think
that's a really really important point
but i think with hindsight i think from
the discussion we've had in the
questions raised today perhaps in future
we must um pay more attention to the
social and government aspects and not
just concentrate fully on on the
environmental aspect right which i agree
are totally very important but i think
we we needed to look at all three
aspects so thank you chair thank you
thank you thank you very much that's
that's very helpful to have the opinion
of the chair of audience standards with
us today thank you very much councillor
muller thank you chancellor fleming
yes thank you um
thank you very much um i feel i
i would like to say something um on the
environmental aspect of esg
and our approach to our investments um
and um to possibly help to try and
respond to some of the questions which
counselor mellon councillor mathson have
have put to us earlier um i'd like to
speak to two points which have been
raised
and one is that our approach to esg
encompasses the full intended meaning of
all three components of the esg
and including especially that of
environment and the second point i'd
like to just say something on is our
approach
to investing in the fossil fuel industry
in particular oil and gas
i think we all recognize that climate
change poses a serious threat to the
destabilization
of global economies in decades to come
and a simplistic view of the e in the
esg
can be interpreted as
climate change caused by fossil fuel
production and consumption
and the s in the esg as diversity
equality and inclusion programs but and
i've researched this
from a number of current sources
this is
a very narrow and generally
internationally unaccepted definition
the
e includes a much broader range of
considerations taking into account a
company's utilization of natural
resources land and water and the effect
of its operations on biodiversity and
the environment generally
both in direct operations and across
supply chains and is this last
definition of environment in esg
that this council intends to follow
the second point moving on to fossil
fuels and again please bear with me
because there's an awful lot to say on
this and i realize time is limited the
core question against the backdrop of
rising emissions
of global warming global warming
pollutants
is a simple one should today's oil and
gas companies be viewed
as part of the problem or could they
possibly be crucial in solving it
now most of the large integrated energy
companies are already establishing esg
policies
they recognize that they must meet
ethical and esg objectives in order to
meet their own investor expectations
both here and in america and hong kong
etc everywhere around the world and
they're engaging in a path towards
energy transition you're looking to find
bp sitting in 2050 with nothing to do
and i think there will be plenty for it
to do
i'll just give a couple of examples of
some of the work that oil and gas
companies have been doing
exxon mobil has announced a four-prong
sustainability framework that includes
investing three million dollars in
carbon capture and storage
bp has invested
significantly in wind solar and hydrogen
and is one of the largest contributors
to re renewable organizations globally
in 2020 they digested
operations and reduced the company's
overall emissions by almost six megatons
making an initial step towards their
stated goal
of reducing emissions by 41 megatons by
2050 and finally kinder morgan american
firm recently formed a new unit to
explore green energy including storage
and handling of liquid
renewable transportation fuels such as
ethanol renewable diesel and hydrogen
in the
the coming energy transition is supposed
to be almost an almost complete switch
from an energy basis
which gets 80 percent of its energy from
hydrocarbons to virtually none
by 2050
to do that in less than 30 years and
accomplish the changes that we expect is
a very tall order
it is dislikes
and
is unlikely to work without the
participation and financial support of
the large players
so in conclusion what i would like to
say is without the oil and gas industry
transformation of the energy sector
will be far more difficult and more
expensive and possibly and this is not
just my opinion not achievable at all i
therefore see no reason to divest from
ethical major fossil fuel linked firms
in any sense and many reasons to do the
contrary
thank you
thank you councillor fleming very
powerful
councillor brewster
thank you madam chair um actually
councillor fleming has just spoken about
the areas that i wanted to speak about
but um uh so i thank her for doing that
but i think we mustn't lose sight of the
fact that these um
uh fossil fuel companies at the moment
are working on the um
the sustainable and uh
fuels
um
and really if we cut them short now and
try to get rid of them um we may well in
the future be
using or losing the the the the thing we
very much want to see
in terms of sustainable fields
so thank you councillor fleming put it
so much better than i could have done
thank you
thank you very much gerard
so based upon
this discussion i'm minded to
accept the recommendations in 3.1
so thank you everybody for that that
conversation that's been really really
helpful
so that finishes all the items on our
agenda and the date and time of our next
meeting is scheduled for monday the 7th
of february at 10 30
and that will again be um a virtual
meeting
in the same format as this one has been
uh look forward to seeing you all then
meeting is now closed
you